SPEAKER: Providing a good
user experience for consumers
of your API is crucial.
This work continues even
after you've intentionally
built your API with simple
and intuitive design.
It's also equally important
to enable developers
with self-service tools
to easily find and learn
how to use your API
so they can ultimately
build their app using your
APIs quickly and securely.
Apigee's configurable developer
portal enables app developers
with API discovery, exploration,
learning, and testing.
And so in this episode,
we will learn more
about the developer portal.
Whether the APIs you build are
for internal or external use,
the developer portal
enables API developers
to publish your catalog
of API products,
offer detailed documentation
for each of those products,
create an easy app developer
onboarding process,
have mechanisms to create
an app and an API key.
You can even try out your API.
You can also leverage
the default templates
or customize the
portal's styling
to suit your company's branding.
And what's nice is
that it's connected
to your Apigee console,
which centralizes
all your API management
tasks in one place, including
API analytics, which we will
dive in another episode.
Now let's take a quick tour
from both a publisher's view
at setting up the portal, as
well as the consumer's view
accessing the portal.
In prior episodes,
we talked about how
to create a Cloud project,
enable Apigee APIs, creating
an evaluation org, then
log into Apigee.google.com,
build your API Proxy, and later
bundle one or more proxies
into an API product.
Now to create a portal
from the same console,
visit Publish, Portals,
the plus Portal
button to create a new portal.
Since I already have one, I will
click Cancel and use this one.
Next, we will see the
different items you
can configure in your portal.
Now we added an
existing API product
by selecting API Catalog, the
plus sign in the top corner,
and then select an
API product, then
select Next to go to
the API Details page.
You also need to
check the box called
Publish to be able to be
listed in the catalog.
Next, you need to associate
the documentation for that API
product.
The format of the documentation
is an open API specification,
which is an industry standard.
In this demo, I already created
one for this simple proxy.
You can then add an image
and associate categories
that help make the API
searchable on the portal.
Then click Save.
Once you have added the product
and publish the documentation,
you can actually visit
the developer portal
to see what it looks like
by selecting the Live Portal
link to launch it.
This is a developer
portal that Apigee
provides to get you started.
And to make changes to
the pages and theme,
you can return to your
portal's configuration options,
and then choose a page--
for example, Get Started.
This will open the
page editor where
you can make changes using
markdown's simple formatting,
which is then converted
to HTML to render
the page in your browser.
Now let's see the view
from an external app
developer visiting the portal.
App developers first sign up
to create an account and login,
so they can create an
app and get an API key.
After that, this
is the landing page
for a consumer app developer.
They can see all the
API products available
and explore their details.
I can view those endpoints
to understand how they work,
and I can actually execute
a call to try it out.
If I don't have an API
key, I get an error.
To create my own
API key, I visit
New app, Enter App Details,
and enable the API product I
wish to use, and click Create.
Now Apigee registered my
app and assigned a key
to it, which I can quickly copy.
Now let's go back into the API
product and test out the key.
Click Authorize.
And from the
dropdown, you can see
that it knows I already
created an app, which
I select and click Authorize.
Now I can make a
call, which you can
see it points to my demo app
inside of my evaluation org
and is using this product.
Great.
So to wrap up, let's
do a small recap.
Apigee provides a
configurable app developer
portal out of the
box, which is publicly
available on the internet where
developers can find your API
catalog, sign up,
register their app
to get an API key to
use with the APIs.
The interactive
API documentation
allows developers to test out
the API while they're also
developing their app.
If you found this episode
helpful, community,
you can subscribe to
learn about more episodes
on getting started with Apigee's
API management tool set.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]